I've opened up DevTools, and
I've navigated to the Network tab.
I'm ready to record so
I will refresh the page.
You can see the three requests for
the three different images,
horse1, horse2, and horse3.
It looks like their sizes
are really different.
Notice how horse2 is almost ten
times bigger than horse1, and
horse3 is also bigger than horse1.
Given that the images look identical,
it seems like there could
be some wasted bytes here.
Inside the Elements pane,
I can find out the actual
dimensions of these three images.
There are a couple of ways doing it.
I'm going to show you a hard way and
then an easy way.
DevTools has this awesome feature where
you can manipulate an element in the dom
by clicking on it up here.
So I've clicked on the first horse.
And then inside the console,
I can access it by typing $0.
When I press Enter,
you see that, hey, its the horse.
To find out the horse's actual width,
I'll simply access
the property naturalWidth.
All right, so
looks like that one is 426.
I'll select horse2.
And now, because horse2 is selected, I
can actually run the exact same command.
It looks like that one
is also 426 pixels wide.
So I'll try the third one.
And ah-ha that one is twice
as large at 852 pixels.
So it looks like these three
images have different sizes.
Okay, now here's the easy
way of figuring that out.
Simply hover over the image,
and you can see it right here.
There is the natural width and height.
Horse2 is the same just
like we saw a second ago.
And then horse3 is twice as large.
So then what could be different
about horse1 and horse2?
As it turns out,
their compression levels are different.
So at this point it's clear that
horse3 is definitely a larger image.
But then what's different
about horse1 and horse2?
If they have the same resolution but
different sizes, well then,
it's pretty clear that they have
different compression levels.
So, the answer to this quiz is that they
have different compression levels and
different resolutions.